[Music]
the government of ethiopia has summoned
the people
and sounded the alarm
at a series of giant rallies in the
capital
the nation now mired in a brutal civil
conflict with the leaders of the region
of tigre the tplf and the residents of
this city have been pressed into service
all able-bodied adults are expected to
fight
[Music]
and their number includes a man who is
synonymous with ethiopia a
record-breaking champion athlete
[Music]
we are brothers
we are sisters
i don't have any problem with anybody
but i have a problem if someone wants to
uh put down my ethiopia my country
highly gabriel selassie is a double
olympic gold medalist turned successful
entrepreneur
but the war now dominates his thinking
if she or he wants to put down my
country ethiopia i'm again
you are saying that the tplf
are doing that if they if they want to
keep you know just if they want to put
ethiopia down
no question
a political dispute between the prime
minister abi ahmed and the leaders of
tigre
has turned into a debilitating year-long
conflict and it threatens to tear the
country apart
foreign countries like the u.s have told
their citizens to leave and the uk did
the same while we were conducting this
interview
that feels like betrayal
i feel really very sad you know you know
ethiopians have a relationship you know
with the whole world with americans over
100 years
germany over 100 years france over 100
years
many countries over 100 years
and okay now ethiopia has a problem how
can you say you know just your people oh
leave their country as soon as possible
leave them
i feel so sad really
the prime minister abi ahmed has gone to
the battlefield saying he'll lead the
army from the front and he's called on
ordinary ethiopians to join him it's a
move the former athlete supports
the rising of the people here in
ethiopia
it's really amazing isn't there a danger
that a lot of the people who are now
preparing to go to the front that they
end up getting killed do they have any
other choice
if there is no ethiopia
what is the next step
would you go to the front
would you fight well i told you i told
you do you have any other choice
tell me
if there isn't just a choice
yeah
but if that meant picking up a weapon a
gun
well i'm a major by the way
i'm a major in police
that's why
don't be surprised if i were holding a
delta weapon because i already
have a weapon
the tplf poses a fundamental threat says
gabriel selassie who trained in the
police as a youngster
but his faith in ethiopia seems
unshakable
is the future of this country
in danger
i don't feel like that honestly speaking
because
ethiopia is protected by god
that's what i believe
every citizen of this country has been
asked to pick a side and gabriel
selassie has made his decision
but they run a terrible risk fighting
for their cause
john sparks sky news in addis ababa